(speech muffled by static)
- [Pilot 3] Oh my gosh, dude.
(suspenseful music)
- [Johnny] It's November 14th, 2004,
about a hundred miles off the coast
of San Diego, California.
The USS Nimitz, one of the US Navy's
largest aircraft carriers is preparing
for deployment to the Persian Gulf.
But the radar technicians
aboard notice something weird.
The military report from that day says
that they notice quote, "multiple objects
descending from around 60,000 feet
down to 50 feet in a matter of seconds."
Very high velocity.
60,000 feet.
A reminder that commercial airplanes fly
at like 36,000 feet.
The report goes on to say
that these objects quote,
"hover for a short time and
depart at super high velocities"
with, quote, "advanced
acceleration capabilities."
At first, these radar techs thought that
their fancy new radar
system was messed up,
so they recalibrated the
radar, but the signal remained.
Something was up here.
- They're telling us they
have a contact on their radar.
They don't know what it
is. They just have a blip.
Well, they've been watching these things,
and what he told me is they had
been looking at these things
as we're driving.
I says, sir, we've been
tracking these things
for about two weeks.
That's, we had been at sea for two weeks.
He goes, this is the first
time we've had planes airborne.
We want you to go see what these are.
- [Johnny] So they sent out
two F/A-18s to investigate.
The report from that day
describes a day of blue skies,
no clouds and unlimited visibility.
These two Navy pilots arrive to the scene,
each with a weapons officer in the back.
They look around and
notice something strange
in the water below.
- So, as we're looking
down off the right side,
the back seater in the
airplane, Jim, he says,
"Hey, skipper, do you,"
and that's about what he gets
out of his mouth and I go,
"What the hell is that?"
- [Johnny] It looks as if
some cross shaped object
the size of a massive
airplane is submerged
right underneath the surface of the water,
and above it, it appears to be boiling.
And just above the boiling
water, an object is hovering.
- And we saw this little
white Tic Tac looking object,
and it's just kind of moving
above the whitewater area.
- Like no predictable movement,
no predictable trajectory.
- Yeah.
- I guess it was just-
- It was just like a ping pong ball.
- No acceleration.
- Very, very random.
- Acceleration.
- [Johnny] The Navy report
describes this object as quote,
"an elongated egg or a Tic
Tac that was uniformly white
across the entire body."
It was approximately 46 feet in length.
One of the pilots with his
weapons officer in the back
wanted to get a closer look.
- So then I go, hey, I'm
gonna go check it out.
- [Johnny] So, he turns this
jet down towards the object.
The other pilot's staying
back to get a wider view.
- So, I'm coming down, and
as I get to 12 o'clock,
as the Tic Tac's doing this,
it literally, it's like it be,
it's aware of us and it just goes bloop,
and it kind of points out towards the west
and starts coming up.
So, now it's obviously
knows that we're there,
whatever this thing is,
it knows that we're there.
So, I'm kind of almost
coming out co altitude
as this thing's coming up.
I'm gonna meet it, and it just,
as it crosses our nose, it just,
it accelerates and literally,
in less than, you know,
probably less than a half second,
it just goes, and it's gone.
- And you saw no visible propulsion?
- Right.
- [Interviewer] No wings or anything-
- No.
- [Interviewer] To no make
it fly in our atmosphere.
- [Johnny] As these two
pilots are heading back
to their aircraft carrier,
they get a radio call from
one of their radar techs.
- I mean, he's like,
hey, sir, you're not gonna believe this,
but that thing is at your cap.
It showed back up. It just popped up.
The other, this is like 60 miles away.
It just reappears.
- [Johnny] Within seconds, 60
miles away, just like that.
By the time they get back to
the Nimitz, the object is gone.
So, they gear up and get
ready to send another jet out
to investigate, and this time,
they make sure that an infrared camera
is strapped to the bottom.
With the camera recording,
they found the Tic Tac again.
Okay, so now we're looking at real data,
real evidence that we can analyze,
get us away from relying
on someone else's memory.
What you're seeing is an object that is
somehow flying through the sky.
These infrared cameras will
usually show a heat signature
of exhaust or some kind
of energy that shows
how an aircraft is being
propelled, something.
But here, there's nothing.
And yet suddenly, this
object in the blink of an eye
blasts away.
And to be clear, we just
showed you the raw clip.
We didn't edit this in any way.
This was back in 2004,
but no one knew about it
and likely never would
until it was leaked in 2007
on a fringe UFO website
called Above Top Secret.
It honestly looked like some kind of
BS conspiracy UFO stuff,
totally disregarded.
But 10 years later, the Pentagon confirmed
that, actually, it's totally legit.
This is authentic Navy footage recorded by
some of the best pilots on earth
showing an unidentified flying object.
"The New York Times" would go on to report
on this pretty deeply and
revealed that this video,
as well as the firsthand accounts
by people who saw this object,
would lead the Pentagon
to create a secret program
to study what's happening here.
And not just this encounter,
but dozens of others.
Something the public wouldn't
hear about until recently.
And that's what this video is about.
- [Reporter] US military officials
have gone before a Congress hearing,
releasing once classified videos
from fighter pilots' cockpits.
- [Reporter 2] 144 unexplained sightings.
(speech muffled by static)
- Wait, pause.
Yes, I know some of you are asking,
am I actually doing this?
Yes, I'm actually doing this.
We're doing a deep dive on UFOs and no,
it's not some bait and
switch storytelling device
where I try to trick you into believing me
and then, like, tell you to
not believe everything you see.
I'm actually doing this.
I'm applying my
journalistic lens to a topic
that, in my opinion, has
been thoroughly bastardized
and sensationalized by the
likes of the History Channel,
UFO fanatics and Hollywood.
I wanna do the opposite of all of that.
I wanna actually evaluate
the facts, because, honestly,
there are some really
compelling facts here.
So this is not Roswell.
It's not aliens landing
at a school in Zimbabwe.
It's not Bob Lazar claiming
that he worked on UFO tech
back in the '70s.
I'm not touching any of that stuff.
Maybe if this video does well,
I will open up those cans of worms.
Today, all I'm looking
at are the hundreds of
evidence-based sightings of
stuff flying around in the air
that the US military has observed
but has concluded they
don't know what it is.
That's it. Let's do this.
Oh, and by the way,
next week's video is live
right now over on Nebula.
You can watch it ad free right this minute
if you go sign up for Nebula.
Link in the description,
no code necessary.
Okay, let's get back to it.
In many ways, the 2004 Tic Tac
event is the starting point
for a new era of UFO investigations.
And again, big props
to "The New York Times"
for breaking the news that the Pentagon
had been investigating UFOs in secret
since at least 2007.
It was a program that Harry Reid,
a Democratic senator from Nevada,
had personally been asking for.
Big alien guy, that Harry Reid, huh?
"The Times" reporting also revealed
that there were other videos.
In 2014, a Navy jet was chasing
a fleet of strange objects
on the east coast of the United States.
I mean, listen to this radio chatter.
- [Pilot] There's a whole
fleet of them. Look on the ASA.
- [Pilot 2] Oh my gosh.
They're all going against the wind.
The wind's 120 knots from the west.
- [Pilot] Well if there's-
- [Pilot 2] Look at that thing.
- [Pilot] It's rotating.
- The next year in the same area,
a Navy pilot captured a small round object
traveling at what looks
like very high speeds
over the water.
- [Pilot 3] Whoa! Got it.
Woo hoo!
What the fuck is that thing?
- [Pilot 4] Did you box a moving target?
- [Pilot 3] No, I took an auto-track.
- [Pilot 4] Oh, okay.
- [Pilot 3] Oh my gosh, dude. Wow.
(speech muffled by static)
- [Pilot 4] Look at that fly.
- In 2019, some Navy sailors
were on board this destroyer
when they pointed a camera through
their night vision goggles
and captured this video.
On March 4th, 2019, a weapons officer
sitting in the back of a fighter jet
captured these pictures of
a quote, "metallic blimp,
a sphere and an acorn."
And then, there was this incident in 2021
where a Navy pilot was filming
out his window with a phone
and caught this.
Yeah, you probably missed it.
Let's just slow that down. This.
Like, what is this thing?
These videos and images
were shot by Navy pilots
who were on duty and have
confirmed to be authentic
by the United States government.
And these are just a few
of hundreds of sightings
under investigation by the Navy,
many of which remained classified for,
we all know what I'm gonna say,
national security reasons.
Not undermining it. I'm
just saying like, ugh.
It's just like the catchall
for all things I want to know.
Got a little outta control there.
(suspenseful music)
As more and more of these
unidentified flying objects
were being reported and
talked about in the public,
the Department of
Defense finally assembled
an official unidentified
aerial phenomenon task force.
UAPs is what the government now calls UFOs
because UFOs, you know, again,
has been completely tainted by this stuff.
- [Narrator] A UFO sighting
over multiple cities.
- [Speaker 2] I don't
know what the hell it is.
- [Narrator] An extraterrestrial event
that changed the course of history
and an alien abduction witnessed
by no less than six people.
- When you read through these reports
and you can start to see why
the government wants to study this stuff.
And no, it's not just
because Harry Reid is, like,
into aliens or whatever.
The government says it itself that
it's interested in this
because of national security.
Who's flying around in our airspace
without our authorization,
and why are they behaving in weird ways
that we don't understand?
But they also mention the
safety of their pilots
and their very expensive hardware.
This new committee has been
coming out with reports,
and they state very clearly
why they're doing this.
First, the Pentagon is
worried that these UAPs
may be quote, "part of a
foreign collection program
or indicative of a major
technological advancement
by a potential adversary."
Counterintelligence, quote,
"UAP pose a hazard to safety
of flight and could pose a broader danger
if some instances represent
sophisticated collection
against United States military activities
by foreign governments, or,"
crucially, "demonstrate a
breakthrough aerospace technology
by a potential adversary."
Translation, we don't really
know what these things are
and that kind of scares us.
Oh, and safety.
- When do you start getting a
thought that, like, what is,
what the fuck is this thing?
- So, that happened when
we visually saw one.
There were two aircraft
from my squadron, VFA 11,
and they flew, took
off as a flight of two.
That means they're essentially
flying in a formation
like this.
And as they hit the area,
one of these objects went
right between the aircraft.
- We have a very strict
system for controlling
who is flying in our airspace to make sure
that things don't run into each other
because random stuff flying around
could risk the lives of the pilots
and these $67 million weapons.
So, when something like this
happens, it's a huge deal.
They immediately abort
whatever they're doing,
and they return to their ship to, like,
discuss what the hell just happened.
- And you know, he was
just sitting there saying,
"Hey, you know, I almost hit
one of those damn things,"
and we all knew what he was referring to,
even though we didn't
necessarily have a name for it
just because we were seeing these so much.
And he described it, you know.
He described it just as a
black or dark gray cube.
And that cube was inside of a
clear or translucent sphere,
and essentially the the apex
with the corners of that cube,
best he could tell,
were touching that inside of that sphere.
- Wait, hold on. Did you catch that?
Not the weird cube inside of a
translucent sphere, whatever.
We'll get to that later.
To me, what's actually more compelling
about what this guy just said is.
- Because we were seeing these so much.
- He is saying that these pilots
have been seeing these things.
- You know, essentially, all the time.
- Wow. Yeah.
Like yeah, I get it.
The translucent cube thing
is, like, more tantalizing,
but, like, the fact
that these pilots report
seeing these UAPs, these UFOs,
all the time, day after day,
week after week, that, to me,
is more compelling evidence
that we need to evaluate here.
And, like the 2004 Tic Tac
case that we talked about
at the beginning.
- This was happening because
we upgraded our radar,
the best we could tell.
- These Navy personnel
at first don't believe
what they're seeing.
They think that their
instruments are probably broken.
- And then people started to
try to fly by it and see it.
And at this point, you know,
I would say maybe 80
to 90% of our squadron
had probably seen one of these
on the radar at this point.
Everyone was aware of it.
- So, according to some of these accounts,
you've got a bunch of Navy
pilots seeing weird stuff
all the time, both on radar
but also with their infrared cameras.
But are you gonna be the guy
who goes to your superior
in the Navy and say, like,
hey, I saw another UFO today.
You don't wanna be like the UFO crazy.
You're gonna get kicked
out of the freaking, like,
most superior pilot corps
in the world because, like,
you're seeing UFOs.
These pilots have talked about
how there's a real stigma
with reporting this stuff,
so a lot of 'em just sort of keep quiet.
But it was when that near
crash happened that now
these pilots are literally
required to file safety reports
of what happened.
And this is where the Pentagon
and lawmakers who fund them
were forced to take these
UFOs more seriously.
- We know that our service
members have encountered
unidentified aerial phenomenon,
and because UAPs pose
potential flight safety
and general security risk,
we are committed to a focused effort
to determine their origins.
- This is where I start
to get pretty excited
about the potential here because, look,
this is like a real high up
person in our intel community
in the military who's talking about
getting more data on this, on studying it.
Keep going. Mr. Moultrie.
- Our effort will include
the thorough examination
of adversarial platforms
and potential breakthrough technologies,
US government or commercial platforms,
allied or partner systems
and other natural phenomenon.
- Scientists, military leaders,
even some politicians
are joining the crowd
of true believers with the
US Navy task force called in.
- So, by 2020 this is now,
like, becoming a thing,
and this is probably why
you've heard about it recently.
This task force was
formed, and it represents
the first time since 1969
that the US government
has officially or at least
publicly acknowledged
the significance of studying UFOs.
- There is something there,
measurable by multiple instruments,
and yet, it seems to move in directions
that are inconsistent with
what we know of physics
or science more broadly.
And that, to me, poses
questions of tremendous interest
and, as well as potential
national security significance.
- Okay, wait, pause, just, yep.
Inconsistent with the
laws of physics. Yep.
Very tantalizing. Let's just pause.
We're talking about UFOs
here, and I feel obligated
to just check in
and make sure we're all
on the same page, okay?
First, we know it is a
fact that the US government
has observed stuff in the
air that they can't explain.
The evidence that I've
presented here is solid,
solid sources, solid reporting.
If I had evidence like
this for any other story
that I'm doing, I'd be like,
this is solid evidence.
Let's put it in the story. Okay?
We know that it's true.
(suspenseful music)
Oh, and it's not just the few events
that I've mentioned here.
According to this report, there's been 144
of these instances either
from the US military
or government personnel,
and 80 of these reports have been gathered
from quote, "multiple sensors,"
meaning from multiple perspectives,
multiple perspectives or tools,
which is like a thousand
times better than, like,
one pilot just saw something
and is remembering it.
Even if said pilot is someone like
Lieutenant Commander Alex Dietrich,
who, when you read this profile
from "The Washington Post"
on her, seems to be a pragmatic,
highly credible Navy pilot
from one of the most
specialized flight programs
in the world.
- I don't identify as a UFO person.
- Like, these pilots don't have incentives
to make this stuff up.
And yet, the fact remains
that their instruments
for measuring and observing the world
is the human eyes, brain
and long-term memory,
which is a pretty faulty and inaccurate
data collection tool.
So, when I see something
like 80 of these sightings
being collected from multiple sensors,
it makes all the difference for me.
Okay, so that's number one.
The US government has seen this.
They don't know what it is,
and it's been collected well.
Number two, the other thing we know
is that they've taken it seriously.
This is a concern for them.
The US Department of
Defense is funding an effort
to investigate, study and
analyze what is happening here,
which, again, is awesome.
Funding research is the only
way that we know anything
about the world.
It's so much better than
hearing a few people riff
on what they saw.
Science and research is our best antidote
to the faulty, story driven human brain.
And indeed, the task force has come to
some pretty useful conclusions.
- Since the release of
that preliminary report,
UAP task force database
has now grown to contain
approximately 400 reports.
- They went back and they looked at
every one of these reports,
analyzed all the data they could.
And when you do that, you
start to see these incidents
come into perspective.
Remember this video of the
fast moving round thing
that the pilot was freaking out about?
Turns out that the Pentagon analyzed this,
knowing everything they know
about where the jets were
and what tools were being
used to record this moment.
And they calculated that
this was actually just, like,
an optical illusion.
Like, this object actually
isn't moving that fast,
only like 30 miles an hour.
Or remember this video of
the triangles in the sky
filmed off of that destroyer?
It turns out that this was
more just quirky optics.
- [Scott] We're now reasonably confident
that these triangles correlate
to unmanned aerial systems in the area.
The triangular appearance
is a result of light
passing through the night vision goggles
and then being recorded by an SLR camera.
- These objects are
probably foreign drones
trying to spy on US military maneuvers,
yet they might not be triangle in shape,
but, like, that's still
really useful information.
We should know if there
are foreign adversaries
floating over our Navy destroyers.
Or this video of a UFO shaped object
being chased by an F-18.
- [Pilot] There's a whole
fleet of them. Look on the ASA.
- What makes this video so weird is
how the object is behaving,
unexpected ways, kind
of turning and rotating.
- [Pilot 2] Look at that thing.
- [Pilot] It's rotating.
- Well, once again with
a little bit of analysis,
this weird movement is
actually just another quirk
of the image sensors that
they use in the military
on these specialized
cameras that make objects
look like they're moving in strange ways,
when, really, if you just
saw it with your eye,
it wouldn't be that weird.
There's this guy, Mick West,
who's probably the most
passionate debunker of, like,
anything weird going on here.
He does a really compelling deep dive on
an explanation for this,
why this object looks like
it's moving so strangely.
I mean if you want to go into it,
it's like another optical
mixed with camera sensors
mixed with gimbal equipment
and rotating compensation mechanisms.
Yeah, you get the point,
but we still don't know
what this object is,
but at least we have more clarity
on why it looks weird to us with our eyes
when we're watching on
a video on the internet.
The Pentagon recently came out
and told "The New York Times"
that most of this stuff is actually
just foreign spies flying around,
spying on US military
activities or weather balloons
or other airborne tracks,
and further specifying
that a lot of this stuff
that looks weird to us looks weird
because it was recorded
on gear that is classified
and is built for a specific purpose
that we don't have
access to understanding,
leading to some strange looking imagery.
Really convenient, Pentagon.
And yet, another fact
in all of this is that
many of these videos have
not been officially declared
a foreign drone and, in
fact, remain unexplained.
And that's after analysis.
One of those unexplained
sightings was this one from 2004,
the one we started this video
on, the Tic Tac incident.
(suspenseful music)
The report often cites lack
of good data and, indeed,
what we have here is not the best,
but we still have four sets of eyeballs.
We have an official Navy
report gathering facts
from that day,
technicians seeing this thing
descend from 60,000 feet
down to 50 feet in a matter of seconds,
hovering stationary on the
radar for a short amount of time
and then departing at high
velocities, high turn rates.
This video, which is kind
of uninspiring and grainy
and not very long, but
still shows us something,
with its infrared not
capturing any heat signature,
any means of propulsion
as this thing flies around
at mind boggling speeds.
Since these pilots went
public with their account,
a handful more of Navy
witnesses have come forward
telling their stories
of what they have seen.
And again, I take this all
with a giant grain of salt,
especially when you see
some of these accounts
putting fuel on the fire
in the form of crazy claims
that, I'm intentionally not
gonna go into into them here
because I consider them
deeply outside of the realm
of useful evidence.
But yeah, if you're interested,
you can easily go down the rabbit hole.
This stuff is like
clickbait for every human.
If you do go down the rabbit hole
on some of these other
testimonies or witnesses,
just be careful.
This is powerful, intoxicating stuff.
We all secretly want to believe
that this isn't just,
like, China spying on us.
That's boring.
Our brains are really good
at filling in the gaps
to construct a faulty narrative.
Be careful.
But yeah, that aside, there's
still no satisfying theories
that I could find that
explain the 2004 Tic Tac case.
Could be Russia or Chinese secret drones
or even experimental aircraft
that we ourselves have been developing.
I mean, it's no secret
that powerful countries
spend a lot of time and
resources trying to get
a leg up militarily, trying to find
the next big technological thing.
Like, you can actually find
patents from the US military
that claim to revolutionize
propulsion tech
using, like, anti-gravity
spacecraft, like,
really out there, wild,
weird, theoretical tech
that may or may not exist.
Again, another rabbit hole
I'm not gonna go down.
The 2004 Tic Tac case remains a mystery,
and I have a feeling that it
will be a mystery forever.
We'll probably never
know what this thing is,
and that's because real answers only come
when you have real inquiry with real tools
to measure and analyze real
data from the real world.
People's eyes and brains and memories
are about the worst
thing you can count on,
and yet, we can't ignore credible sources.
- They were always out there, you know.
- [Joe] Always.
- They were out there when we took off.
We'd see them and then we'd go to land.
They would still be out there.
- Like every day?
- Every day.
- But that's not proof of anything.
To me, if they're always out there,
we should be able to come
up with a way to study them,
and the US government agrees.
- This often limited
amount of high quality data
and reporting hampers our
ability to draw firm conclusions
about the nature or intent of UAP.
- Step one in all this is gonna be
to decouple the study of UFOs,
which is something we should totally do,
from the quick conclusion
that people jump to
that we are being visited by aliens
from a different star system.
That is what created the
stigma in the first place.
That is why people are embarrassed
to talk about this stuff.
We need to decouple them. There are UFOs.
We should study them and
see what they actually are.
But am I saying that
these absolutely aren't
alien spacecraft coming
from other planets?
No, I'm not saying that
at all. I don't know.
What I'm saying is that I
haven't seen anything close
to the burden of evidence
required for me to believe
that that's what these things are.
What I have seen is evidence
of weird, unidentified things
flying around, behaving in
ways that are potentially
beyond our mainstream
understanding of physics.
I mean, potentially.
So yes, I'm totally open to
these things being aliens.
I'm open to literally anything.
My issue is that people see this,
and our brains automatically
do the easy thing,
which is to fill in the blanks.
Suddenly, aliens are the
explanation. My brain does it, too.
It scares me. It's not
the right approach here.
I mean, I'm aware that it literally
is almost a statistical impossibility
that we're the only intelligent
life forms in this universe.
Definitely not the the case.
So yeah, maybe they found a way to travel
to our little speck of dust planet,
and they wanted to visit
and look at us or something.
I don't know.
I'm totally open to it, but again,
I have zero reason to believe that
because there's no evidence
that points to that as the explanation.
- [Announcer] Seven, six, five.
- But then there's the flip side,
the juicier part of this for me,
which is, who's to say we aren't
the awe inspiring creatures ourselves?
A hundred years ago,
most people were still
riding around on horses.
They would've looked at our
modern world, all of this
and thought that, certainly,
aliens had come to take over.
Certainly, some crazy magician had come
and reshaped the entire planet,
and that's exactly what happened.
Crazy scientific breakthroughs
happen all the time.
I mean, just this year,
the Nobel Prize in physics
went to a team of physicists
laying the foundation
for quantum communication,
like real-time communication
that essentially bypasses the
classical laws of physics.
What I'm trying to say here
is we don't need to treat UFOs
like religion.
We don't need to believe.
Instead of cobbling
together the scant evidence
that we have to fit some
narrative that we want to believe,
let's go out there and
gather data and analyze it
and build a body of knowledge about this.
Let's poke at these
phenomena and figure out
what the hell is going on in our airspace,
at the very least to keep us safe,
but potentially so that we
can discover something new,
something that we can
observe, measure, analyze
and learn from.
Wait, wait, wait, don't go yet.
They released the report.
The Pentagon released the report, like,
right before we published this video.
Like, we were waiting for
them to release the report,
and then they didn't.
So, we filmed the video and I cut my hair,
and then they released the
freaking report about the update,
the 2022 Annual Report on
Unidentified Aerial Phenomena,
UAP, baby.
We've gone through this,
and the update is that
they're actually studying this stuff.
This report goes through
and shows a Pentagon
that is very interested in doing more
to gather data on this,
which is really great news.
There have been 366 new reports of UAP.
They think that over
half of them are, like,
airborne clutter or drones
or balloon like entities,
but 171 of these reports
remain totally unidentifiable.
They don't know what they
are, and they even mention
that some of them continue
to demonstrate quote,
"unusual flight characteristics."
They even say that they're
talking to allies about this
to try to get to the bottom
of what these UAP are.
So yeah, the report is out.
I'll link it in the sources.
It's a pretty good read
if you're into this stuff.
I want to tell you that next
week's video is live right now.
You can watch it right this second.
It's over on Nebula.
I publish all of my videos a week early,
and it's over on Nebula, no ads.
The video is a map
explainer that goes over
all of the major coups
that the US has committed
over the years to, like, depose leaders
and put in leaders that they like.
Spoiler alert, there's
been a bunch of 'em,
and we mapped them.
You can go watch that video
right now, but it's not just me.
All of my favorite creators are on Nebula,
because it is a creator owned platform
where we all publish our best stuff,
not just our videos that we
put here ad-free and early,
but also originals,
things that you can't find anywhere else,
like RealLifeLore's "Modern Conflicts"
or PolyMatter's "China Actually."
These are really cool series
that you can't find anywhere else.
Nebula is a giant repository
of really amazing stuff.
This video actually isn't
sponsored by Nebula.
The reason I'm plugging it right now
is because I don't have
a sponsor for today.
And I want to tell you that
if you sign up for Nebula,
not only do you get access
to my videos a week early
and ad free,
as well as access to all this other
amazing, exclusive content,
but you're also directly
supporting our channel.
It's four bucks a month
or 40 bucks a year,
which is like $3 and 33 cents a month,
and a portion of your subscription
goes directly to funding
the creation of more videos like this.
This isn't some, like, venture
backed, like, tech company.
This is a creator owned streaming platform
that we're all building together,
and you subscribing to it not
only gets you all these perks,
but also helps support us.
So, if that's interesting to
you, I really appreciate it.
(playful music)